hello last episode was very interesting
it took a 180 back flipped into infinity
my god I can't believe it
now I'm actually scared of opening this
game like I don't I was even scared and
just keep playing I'm like nope thank
you very much that's enough of this
thank you
I opened the game files and happy
thoughts
wow that's that's a Yuri
well I guess she's dead now let's start
this game and see what the heck how else
is gonna happen
III don't want me to start it before I
launch the game okay so he it's still
cheerful
okay well it's definitely not suitable
for children now we've learned oh look
at that oh wait what
can I even load this file oh the file is
missing or corrupt the safe file is
corrupt starting a new game Oh what but
I have I had a feeling this would happen
oh my god I have her old file I don't
want to mess with the game files but
what happens if I coffee her in oh
whatever let's keep playing for now I've
seen an annoying girl running towards me
okay we know this oh wow
however I just saw an idol in front of
the crosswalk in leg okay so her name is
Oh
oh great is it crashing no it's not an a
hit a like any of it mornings are
usually the worst being surrounded by
couples okay meanwhile but I have no
motivation to join any clubs
I prefer I'm perfectly content just
getting by oh my god
all my saves are gone I'm probably I
think I skipped some dialog but
basically it seemed like we're acting as
if Saori never existed I'm perfectly
conscious just getting by on the average
while spending my free time on games and
anime there's always anime club but it's
not like there would be any girls in it
anyway the school days or nerds ever and
it's over before I know it after I pack
up my things I stare blankly at the wall
looking for an ounce of motivation clubs
that really aren't any that interests me
besides most of them would probably be
way too demanding for me to want to deal
with I guess I have no choice but to
start with the anime club oh my god who
is this pgb Oh Monica Monica oh oh my
goodness I totally didn't expect you to
to see your hair it's been a ride right
ah yeah it has oh yeah we knew Monica
from before
oh my god Monica smiles sweetly we do
know each other well we rarely talked
but we were in the same class last year
Monica was probably the most popular
girl in class smart beautiful athletic
basically completely out of my league
so having her smile at me so genuinely
feels a little why what did you cover
for her anyway uh I just been licking
first-time supplies to use for my clip
do you know if there's any construction
paper in here Americus um guess you
could check the closet you're in the
debate club right ha ha about that I
actually quit the debate clip really you
quit
yeah to be honest I can't stand all the
politics around the major class if it's
like nothing but arguing about the
budget and publicity and how to prepare
for it whence we know this I'd much
rather take something I personally enjoy
and make something special about it
in that case what club did you decide to
join actually I'm starting an ear with a
literature Club literature that sounds
kind of dull and I just realized Monica
damn how many members do you have so far
um yeah it's kind of embarrassing but
there's only three of us so fair it's
really hard to find new members for
something that sends their bearing well
I can see that but it's really not
pairing at all you know literature can
be anything
reading radit poetry I mean one of my
members even keeps her manga collection
in the classroom wait really
yeah it's funny really she always insist
that manga is literature tea it's such a
South Park voice I mean she's not wrong
I guess and besides mm is the name is
man did Monica say she
[Music]
hey Pittsburgh by any chance are you
still looking for a club to join
oh what a weird coincidence ah I mean I
guess so but in that case it's there any
chance you could do me a big favor
I won't ask you to join bet if you could
at very least visit my club it would
make me really happy
please well I guess I have no reason to
refuse besides how could I ever refuse
someone like Monaco sure I guess I could
check it out oh I'll say you're really
sweet pizza pad you know that it's
nothing really
shudder go then I look for my I look for
materials in edit and they remain hidden
and thus today marks the day I sold my
soul to Monica and her irresistible
smile Wow remember that so we actually
can't reach our save so it's like the
game reached a next stage or something I
really thought like we would go back in
saves and stuff to make something's
different i timidly follow Monica across
the school and upstairs a section of the
school I rarely visit being generally
used for third-year classes and
activities Monica full of energy swings
open the classroom door and Bay it
habitats a guest with me thank you
Hey a guest seriously you bought a boy
way to kill the atmosphere debits I mean
that's okay but anyway welcome to the
clip pity pay all words escape me in the
situation this club it's full of
incredibly cute girls Oh
so let me guess you're Monica's
boyfriend right she gave mass no I am
NOT
Natsuki the girl with a sour attitude
whose name is apparently not Suki is one
I don't recognize her small figure makes
me think she's probably a first-year any
anyway this is not Suki energetic as
Yeshua and this is Yuri the vice pres
name so Yuri became the vice president
it's nice to meet you
Yuri who appears compared ibly more
mature and timid seems to have a hard
time keeping up with someone like and
that's the key
yeah it's nice to meet both of me so I
so I ran into pizza pear in a classroom
and he decided to came check out the
Claire isn't that great wait Monica
didn't I tell you to let me know in
advance
before you brought anyone new I'm going
to well you know sorry sorry
I didn't forget that but I just happened
to run into him in that case I should at
least make some tea right oh yeah that
would be great
where did you came today the PTP the
girls have a few deaths arranged to form
a table
Yuri walks to the corner of the room and
opens the closet
meanwhile Monika and that's Achatz sit
across from each other so I wonder I
feel like someone's gonna die next right
we're gonna get the same thing happening
we know Yuri's technically cut herself
so she could be dealing with the same
issues maybe maybe we pick Natsuki this
time and then Yuri ends up dead and then
it would pick Yuri and nuts again some
dead anyway just speculating still
feeling awkward I take a seat next to
Monica so I know you didn't really plan
it chemically but what makes sure you
feel right at home
okay it's president of literature Club
it's my duty to make a clip fun and
exciting for everyone I'm surprised
there aren't more people in the club yet
it must be hard to starting a new club
you could put it that way now many
people are very interested in putting
all the effort into setting something
brand new especially with something that
doesn't grab your attention like
literature since we've already read this
I don't know okay so this is the end of
day one
oh wait nuts the king
[Music]
interesting concept you've unlocked a
special poem would you like to read it
what does that mean a dream I was
wondering an abandoned warehouse at
night I was lost looking for an exit I
just wanted to go home
I came upon a huge empty room its
ceiling and walls beyond the deep
blackness my steps were quick in order
to hurry to the other side or to a wall
anything suddenly the ground was no
longer beneath my feet I stepped into a
hole of indeterminate width I fell for a
good five seconds before crashing into
warm water figuring out which way was up
I surfers myself the air was humid and
the sun's of my splashing Rev Rev Rev
Rev herbart I don't know how to say that
reverberated and Leslie my vision was
completely swallowed by the dark with
one hand I could feel the damp metal
wall of the container my lungs were
already getting tired what what was that
for I really enjoy hearing your thoughts
on the poems by the way
[Music]
should we stick with URI or should we
try since we already tried URI I'd say
we try for netsuke this time so
unrestrained okay never mind playground
is definitely her games is definitely
her socks is probably her vanilla is
probably her smile is probably her anime
is definitely her beauty excitement
cheer puppy ahead party hey peace flower
hop skipping ocean this is a lot easier
than before I love the music
even when Sayuri died the music was so
beautiful
jumpy bouncing hey [ __ ] its back
glad to see you didn't run away oh hey
now don't worry this might be a little
strange for me but at least I keep my
word well I'm back at the literature
Club I was last to come in so everyone
else is already hanging out oh wow haha
thanks for keeping your promise big
thing I hope oh my god it's sorry I hope
this isn't too overwhelming of a
commitment for you making jab headfirst
into literature when you're not
accustomed to it oh wow oh come on what
he deserves any slack you already had to
be dragged here by Monica I don't know
if you plan to just come here and hang
out on what but if you don't take it
seriously then you won't see the end of
it
oh I'm here now
hello
hits me mighty gay that's a you find
yourself stuck we did saying Monica and
manga my sweet fully defeated that's a
good plots back in her seat I'm sorry
its back well make sure to put your your
comfort first okay I'm gonna skip to
I'm gonna skip to the poem reading oh
wow let it just change pitch the suckers
changed pitch that's Christ can you
believe this get this is okay
and if tilt that a lot I just notice to
the background
oh my god it's making me motion sick
dude oh thank god whoa
[Music]
all right I hear not to get under Nicks
exasperated sigh from the cot from
within the closet she seems to be
annoyed by something I approached her in
case she needs a hand okay you looking
for something in there [ __ ] what what
did you Monica Monica is definitely like
some sort of Saint Ian being I don't
know it's funny I had an idea of a
horror game similar to this I think I
mentioned it before of having like a a
game where the the the monster in the
game knows you're playing the game or
breaking the fourth wall before
undertale or whatever but I just thought
that idea would be so much more
interesting it's really cool to see this
putting in life it's such a creative
game instead of all the fineness of
Freddy [ __ ] sorry wrong time to have
a little rant but there you go she never
puts my stuff back in the right spot
what's the point of keeping your
collection organized if someone else is
just gonna mess it up not to get slides
a bunch of stacked books and boxes
across the shelf manga you read manga
right ah sometimes manga is one of those
things where you can't admit you're
really into it and too until you figure
out where the other person stands yeah I
can see that how did you know anyway I
heard you bring it up at some point
besides it's kind of written on your
face and your pimples what's that
supposed to mean I see there's a lone
volume of manga amidst a stack of
various books on the side of one of the
shelves curious I pull that out of the
stack finish that's to get snatches it
out of my hand then she turns to a box
of manga and slips the volume right into
the middle of the rest
[Music]
seeing a box set with one miss book
missing is probably the most irritating
sight in the world I know that feel
hashtag relatable I get a closer look at
the box
she's admiring how thick girls it's as
soon as I never heard of in my life that
probably means it's either way out of my
demographic or it's simply terrible
you're not gonna judge if you're not
gonna judge you can go do it through the
glass on that door she points to the
classroom door hey I wasn't judging or
anything I I didn't even say anything it
was the tone of your voice but I'll tell
you one thing people cheap I consider oh
wow don't judge a book that's sent you
back in fact Matt segi pulls out the
first volume of perfect girls from the
box I'm gonna show you exactly why she
shows the book I'm writing she shoves
the book right in my hands ah I start
the cover it features four girls in
colorful attires striking anime animated
feminine poses it's exceedingly MOA
don't just stand there
ah nuts I could grab my arm and pulls me
out of the closet she then takes a seat
against the wall beneath the window she
stills she Pat's on the ground next to
her signalizing me to sit there wouldn't
chairs be more comfortable I take my
seat cherish doesn't shavers wouldn't
work we we can't read at the same time
like that why is that I guess it's
easier to sit close together like this
don't just say that you'll make me feel
weird about it that's the key crosses
her arms and scooches an inch away from
me
ha sorry I didn't exactly expect to be
sitting this close to her either not
that I can say it's particularly bad
thing up particularly red thing I open
the book it's only a few seconds before
Natsuki once again inches closer
reclaiming the additional space while
she hopes I won't notice I can feel her
peering over my shoulder much more eager
to begin reading than I am
Wow how long has it been since I read
the beginning hmm you don't go back and
flip through the older volumes every now
and then not really maybe sometimes
after I already finish the theories
what are you Hey are you paying
attention uh I am but nothing really
happened yet so I can't talk at the same
time it looks like it's about a bunch of
friends in high school
typical slice-of-life affair I kind of
grew out of these since it's rare for
the writing to be entertaining enough to
make up for the lack of plot yet are you
sure this isn't boring for you it's not
even though you're just watching me weep
well I'm fine with it if you say so
I guess it's fun sharing something you
like with someone else I always get
excited when I convince ending of my
friends to pick up a series I enjoy you
know what I mean you don't I wouldn't
really know what do you mean don't you
share manga with your friends could you
not rub it in jeez ah sorry
like I could ever get my friends to read
this they just think mind games for kids
I can't even bring it up without them
being all like II you still haven't
grown out of that yet
makes me wanna punch them in the face
ah I know those kinds of people honestly
it takes a lot of effort to find friends
who don't judge
much less friends who are also into it
I'm already kind of elusive so I guess I
gravitated towards the other losers over
time but it's probably harder for
someone like you
well that's pretty accurate wait which
parts I mean I feel like I can't even
keep it in my own room my dad would oh
it would beat the [ __ ] out of me if he
found this then her dad must really hate
manga oh so she's stealing me issues too
they're all girls just dealing with
issues that's seemingly unnoticed on the
surface interesting and there's our eyes
are a bit weird at least it's safe here
in the climate quadrant Kent Monica kind
of said Monica's kind of a jerk about it
oh I just can't win King well and paid
off in the end in name I mean Here I am
reading it well it's not like that souls
any of my problems maybe but at least
you're enjoying yourself right so okay
you must be kidding right
hi behind that's
jeez that's enough are you gonna keep
reading or what yeah yeah I put the page
time passes Natsuki is strangely quiet
now I glanced over at her yeah it looked
like she started to fall asleep
hey Natsuki yeah suddenly nuts the gate
collapses straight into me
hey oh wow oh ho okay
that's stripper oh it keeps going him Oh
Oh Jace that's icky ah Joe okay hair
Monica reaches into her bag and pulls
out some kind of protein bar she throws
it in not Sookie's direction
that's the keys I suddenly lit up again
she snatches a bar from the floor and
immediately tears off the wrapper I told
you not to give me she doesn't even
finish her sentence before stuffing it
in her mouth so they are like controlled
by Monica somehow through protein bars
don't worry if it's patty if she's fat
just happened every now and then that's
why I always keep it snack in my back
for her you're not yourself when you
don't have a snackers anyway why don't
we all share Pam's name
[Music]
my favorite time the poem reading time
Oh whose poem are we gonna read
Natsuki URI Imani can I start when that
Sookie
I told Nancy guy was interested in her
in her poems yesterday it's probably
only fair if I share mine there first
okay let's start with the things I don't
like
first of all okay we know this okay so
during this exchange if you remember
Saori had to jump in to save the
situation are you that full of yourself
no I was full of myself I would delivery
go out of my way to make everything I do
overly cutesy I wasn't the one whose
boobs magically doing science beggar as
soon as boots if I started showing it
I'm netsuke that's a little this doesn't
appeal taking take taking out your own
insecurities on others like that you
really act as young as you look netsuke
look who's talking you wanna be edgy bit
[Music]
edgy sorry that my lifestyle is too much
for someone of your mental age to
comprehend say just say that school you
know if you want to prove something but
stop harassing others with your
seconding attitude you think you can
counterbalance your tuchis personality
just read dressing in acting cute
they only can't think about you it's how
hard you try whoa be careful or you
might cut yourself manage you reek
oh my bad you already know don't you did
you did you execute excuse me have to
cut it myself
what the [ __ ] is wrong with your hand
what if I hear everything
you really think I'm sure he'll be heels
for you after this ah
suddenly Yuri runs towards me I think
she's just noticed I was standing there
it's a pact she's she's just trying to
make me look back
[Music]
Natsuki
oh sorry Yuri oh that's icky then okay
oh hey Monica Wow in Sweden we have this
song that's extremely annoying but also
very catchy going hey hey Monica hey put
a Monica hey Monica hey per day Monica
and and hey Pittsburgh let me step aside
a little bit okay this is so good sorry
about that
they really should have tried to get you
shouldn't have tried to get you in fact
it's probably better for us to stay out
of this or go back inside was there done
yelling hey
sim president I am right I can't even
confront my own cloud memories properly
I just wish I was able to get a little
more assertive sometimes but I never
have it in me to put my foot down
against Eddie you understand me
enemy if he makes you want to spend less
time with others and that's fan I'd be
happy to spend time with even Steve
suddenly nuts to get runs out of the
classroom oh boy this net okay well it
looks like they're dead he didn't mean
it I didn't mean it I didn't mean me
Yuri Oh Yuri said it Yuri's rocking back
and forth in her desk with her palms on
her forehead Yuri
I didn't mean it I I believe you I have
no idea what Yuri might have said to
Natsuki Oh did pizza pie please don't
hate me
please I'm not like this there's
something wrong with me today it's fine
Yuri we know you didn't mean it
besides I'm sure NAT secretly will
forget all about it by tomorrow
completely oh my god is she gonna erase
her anyway in the meetings over so you
can go home now if you want
Yuri looks at me like she wants me to
wants to say something but she keeps
glancing at Monika
you can go first Monika I'd like to stay
a little longer and the president so I
should be the last one I'll wait for you
to be dead well I'm vice president so
please let me take that responsibility
today it kind of sounds like you don't
want me around for something Yuri hey
it's not that it's not that I just I
didn't get much of a chance to discuss
my book with pizza pie
it would just be embarrassing with you
listening yeah I guess I don't really
have a choice do they I'm sorry for
causing trouble but oh that did that did
it did it did it really really I guess
Yuri wanted to tell us
but Monica blocked it out this is so
crazy
[Music]
okay let's go with a let's keep on our
nuts oh wow what a great option I think
I'll go with whistle fireworks huh nabi
peace cute melody candy kitty
smile bunny vanilla vacation fluffy pink
blanket promise pure awesome and puffy I
need extra points for that goddamn that
was awesome another day passes and it's
time for the club meeting already I've
gotten a little more comfortable over
the past couple days entering the room
as usual greeting scene but I come back
pizza pie ah hi Yuri I'm not sure if
it's me or if it's Yuri's expression but
the way of yesterday's quarrel still
hangs in the air in-law and Yuri glances
over our shoulder looking around the
room Natsuki is reading a manga at the
desk
and surprisingly Monica isn't here yet
suddenly Yuri takes my arm and pulls me
on the corner of the room but yesterday
I I really need to apologize
nothing like that has ever happened
before and some something just came over
me I guess
I wasn't acting mentally sound please
don't think we're usually like this
not just me but Natsuki as well Yuri
I'm happy that you were considerate
considerate and apologize you don't have
to worry too much even though I've only
been here a couple days I could tell
something was off yesterday maybe we
were just a little extra sensitive
because it was our first time sharing
poems but whatever it was I didn't make
it didn't make me think any less of you
I had already decided that there's no
way you can be a bad person and now that
you're apologizing I know you didn't
really mean it huh pizza pan don't say
those kind words so frankly they make me
a little too happy I really I'm really
glad they did be such an understanding
person and I'm really glad that you
joined this club everything gets a
little bit brighter with you around and
huh sorry what am I saying right now I
just have you guys hey have you seen
Monica
and no I haven't I was also kind of
wondering where she was mean URI I'm
guessing you haven't either
URI is clearly taken aback by how calmly
nuts the kids they're dressing here no I
haven't jeez this isn't like her at all
did Monica delete her memory I know it's
stupid but I can't help but worry a
little bit what why are you looking at
me with me um Natsuki about yesterday I
just wanted to apologize
we'll see now if it's true I promise I
didn't mean any of the things I said and
I'll do my best to stay under control
for now so what the heck are you talking
about did you do something yesterday
[Music]
jeez I'm sure it was nothing
I don't even remember anything bad
happening you're the gamma person new
words you must back the little thing not
you but but I I'll accept your apology
anyway if it helps you feel better about
it
besides it's kind of nice to hear since
I was always afraid you secretly hated
me or something like that
yeah me me no no that's not at all I
don't hate well you're kind of weird but
I don't hate you either that's a good
turns to me you're still on trial though
you're still a trial boat Hey
suddenly the door swings open savvy and
super sorry ah there you are
I didn't mean to be late I hope you guys
weren't very bad there were anything man
well massacre was I was not a hey what
took you so long anyway ah well my last
period today was study her to be honest
I kinda just like to track a time
that makes no sense though you would
have heard the bell ring at least I must
have not had it since I was practicing
piano piano I'm gonna skip ahead a
little bit because I remember this sorry
I'm not sure if Monica was referring to
the whole club or just me in that case
best of luck thanks
I mean thanks so I didn't miss anything
did I no not really I chose not to bring
up anything that three of us talked
about besides knots again I already run
into the off into the closet
pizza pie since your compliments put me
in a good mood I was wondering if you'd
like to spend some time together today I
mean in the club ah I suppose so I don't
think I could say no to you after you
after you gave that book to me well I
guess I need to make sure knots the key
isn't waiting for me after we finished
reading yesterday she she's fine she's
reading over there see don't think about
it they mate
she needs to be neat new game um again
over you oh my god what what's the story
about anyway well hmm I look at I look
at the cover of the book the book is
titled portrait of Mark cub there's an
ominous looking Isle symbol on the front
cover basically basically it's about the
religious camp that turned into a human
experiment prison and the people trapped
there have had this trait that turns
them into killing machines that lust for
blood but the fact sylheti gets even
worse and they start selectively
breeding people by cutting off their
limbs and if flicks are fixing them - oh
that might be a little bit of a spoiler
it sounds great but anyway I'm really
into it the book I mean not the thing
about the lips that's kind of that's
kind of dark isn't it you're a minute
sound like it was gonna be a nice story
so that the dark turn came out of
nowhere
ha are you not a fan of that sort of
thing pizza pie I swear there was a
different story she was talking about
last time no it's it's not that I mean I
can definitely enjoy those kind of
stories so don't worry I hope so
yeah I totally forgot that you were
Center those things she's so shy and
reclusive on the outside but her mind
seems to be completely different I just
it's just that kind of story it's the
kid it's the kind that challenge you to
look at life from a strange new
perspective when horrible things happen
not just because someone wants to be
evil but mcgirt's the world is full of
horrible people and we're all worthless
anyway then suddenly I'm rambling and
rambling aren't I not again I'm sorry
hey hey don't apologize I haven't lost
interest or anything well I guess it's
fine then but I feel like I should let
you know that I have this problem when I
let things like books and writing fill
my thoughts my hobo oh I kind of forget
to pay attention to other people so I'm
sorry if I end up saying something
strange and please stop me if I start
talking too much that's I really don't
think you need a word that just means
you're passionate about reading the
Lee's secondaries listen it's a
literature club after all ah that's well
that's true in fact I might as well get
started reading it right oh yeah yeah
yes I mean you don't have to bet what
are you saying let me just get the book
I quickly retrieve the book that I had
put him to my bag all right I was sorry
I want to check that [ __ ] game files
that his realized
steam steamapps yada yada come on Doki
Doki there we go there's a file called
II I hate this I can't do anything
nothing and no matter how many times you
play it's all the same it would really
really it would be really really easy to
kill myself right now but that would
mean I don't get to talk to you anymore
oh I want is for you to hate them why is
that so hard
Monica is in the and he's choosing the
game files I think can you hear me
there's a little devil inside all of us
beneath their manufactured perception
their artificial reality is everything
twisted mess of jury dread loathing
judgment elitism self-doubt all
thrashing to escape the feeble hold of
their hosts sleeping through every
little crevice they can find into their
well power starving them all motivation
and desire into their stomach forcing
them to ground their guilt in comfort
food or in a newly opened gash in their
skin hidden only by the sleeves of a
cute new girl such a deplorable tangled
mess it's already presented in every
single one of them that's why I choose
not to blame myself for their action all
I did was untie the knot this is why
what the game looks like
[Music]
okay okay I'll keep it up Mike this is
really interesting such a wonderful
picture all right it's fine if I stay
here right I slip into the seat next to
Yuri's ah
yeah are you sure you seem a little
apprehensive that's okay
this is different my breathing Yuri puts
her hand on her chest as if to feel a
heartbeat I didn't even notice
anyway I'm fine I just need some water
all right don't push yourself Yuri
stands up and practically rushes out of
the classroom what on earth was that
about pizza Pitt did something happened
just now uh I have no idea
Yuri was acting a little strange I guess
so you so you don't know anything sorry
I can't say I do
are you worried about her oh no not
really I was just making sure that you
didn't know didn't do anything to her
no nothing hahaha don't worry I believe
you silly Yuri just does too sometimes
so it's nothing alarming alright if you
say so
anyway why don't we start by sharing our
pants with each other shouldn't we wait
for Yuri well she might be a while so I
just figure we get started with that
here is that okay yeah I was just asking
I stand up I make a mental note or where
I left off the new book then it's
leaping back into my bag
Natsuki what happens then oh she is here
well it's not terrible oh what a great
poem Natsuki this is so good this is a
code I wonder
oh why didn't you come read with me
today I was waiting for you I was
waiting for a long time it was the only
thing I had to look forward to today why
did you ruin it
do you like Yuri more I think you're
better off not associating with her are
you listening to me
Yuri is Yuri it's a sick freak that
should be obvious by now so just play
with me okay you don't hate me pizza pie
do you hate me do you want to make me go
home cry the club is the only place I
feel safe taro and that for me
don't ruin place - stop talking - Yuri
play with me and stayed that's all I
have
play with me No oh my god who should I
show my poem next who would head again
pizza Pitt that's very good all right I
guess I take that as sung it's not going
bad I'm happy that you're applying
yourself maybe soon you'll come up with
the masterpiece I wouldn't count on that
you never know
once you share what you wrote today sure
here you go I gave my phone to Monica
all right Richie up it's back okay we
know this we know this
[Music]
suddenly the door opens Yuri I'm back
did I miss anything
not really well we all started sharing
poems with each other huh
already I'm sorry for being late
no need to apologize we're still have
plenty of time so I'm glad that you took
all the time you needed all right
thanks Monica I suppose I should get my
permanent but anyway you want to read my
poem now I like the way oh sorry that
was your saying there I like the way
this one turned out so I helped you do
to save me the colors they won't bright
beautiful colors flushing and mixed Oh
Co cacophony the noise it won't stop
[Music]
delete her save me load game load me but
that was delete her oh sorry I know it
was kind of Express I'm just trying to
well nevermind there's no point in
explaining anyway here's my Monica's
wedding tip of their day when that
happens don't forget to save the game
you never know when a I'm a talking to
can you hear me tell me you can hear me
anything please help me okay that's my
advice for today thanks for listening
this is so weird
URI I've been waiting for this let's see
what you've written for today nearly
smiles and take a deep breath I just
like holding it what I mean the pointer
not good it's a well there are things
that you could work on but that doesn't
really matter it feels like anything
written by you is a treasure
hahaha thank him out a little awkward
let's move on
here's the poem I wrote you don't have
to like it or anything oh this is
different wheel weeow a rotating wheel
turning an axle grinding bald head
linear a gearbox falling sky 7 holy
steaks a dock ship a portal to another
world a thin rope tied to a thick rope a
torn harness parabolic gearbox expanding
universe time controlled by slipping
cogwheels existence of God swimming with
open waters in all directions drowning a
prey are written in blood a prayer
written in time devouring snakes with
human eyes a thread connecting all
living eyes a calais a yoda scope of
holy stakes exponent show gearbox a sky
of exploding stars a God disproving the
existence of God a wheel rotating in six
dimensions 30 years 40 years of
and a ticking clock a clock that ticks
one second for every rotation of the
planet a clock that ticks 40 times every
time it ticks every second time a bolt
head of holy snakes tied to the existing
of a dock ship to another world a Kelly
otoscope of blood written in clocks a
time devouring prayer connecting a sky
of 40 gears and open human eyes in all
directions breathing gear box breathing
bald head breathing ship breathing
portal breathing snakes breathing god
bleeder breathing blood breathing holy
snakes breathing human eyes breathing
time breathing prayer breathing sky
breathing wheel ahhh ha ha it doesn't
really matter what it's about my mind
has been a little hyperactive lately so
I had to take it out of hardened pain
that that is a pen fell out of your
backpack yesterday so I took it home for
safekeeping and I am I just really liked
the way that it writes so I wrote this
poem with it and now you're touching it
ok
what did I just can we pretend this
conversation never happened you can keep
the poem though oh wow you have unlocked
a special poem would you like to read it
stare at the dot to reveal a special
message what
I love you thanks ok everyone we're all
done reading a chest poem right we have
something we need to get over today so
if everyone could sit in front of the
room is this about the vegetable
well syrup ah do we really have to do
something for the festival it's not like
we can put together anything good and in
just a few days we'll just end up
embarrassing yourself instead of getting
in new members that's a concern of mine
as well
I don't really do well with last-minute
preparation this is gonna go bad don't
worry so much are you going to keep it
simple okay look I know everyone's been
a little more lively ever since pizza
pie joined and we started with some club
activities but it's in this but this
isn't the time for us to become
complacent we still only have four
members and the festival is our only
real chance to find more you know what's
so great about getting new members
anyway we already have enough to be
considered an official Club more mammals
just mean everything gets too noisier
and more difficult to manage that's okay
I don't think you're looking at it the
right way don't you wait to share your
passion with that as many people as you
can to inspire them to find the same
feeling that brought you here in the
first place the literature Club should
be a place where people can express
themself
like they can't do anywhere else it
should be a place so intimate where you
never need to where you never want to
leave I know you feel this way way too
I know blt so that's why we should work
hard and put something together for the
festival even if it's a Vince man wrap
it be ah oh come on you can't take
advantage of p2p to agree with you just
because he doesn't know how to say no to
anything look Monica do you really think
any of us here join the club with other
people in mind URI never even talked
into
pizza pie join as for me I just like it
better here than I do at home and pizza
pie isn't even passionate about
literature in the first place and that's
everyone sorry but you're really the
only one who's interested in finding new
members the rest of us are fine like
this and you are the president and all
and you should really consider our
opinions for once
Monica is clearly taken aback by not
Sookie's world that's not true at all
I'm sure jury and pizza pie wants to get
more members to write I don't know by
yury but I'm kind of indifferent if I
showed as much enthusiasm as Monica
wanted then I would probably be lying
still it's it's up to me to rescue this
situation no NAT Sookie's right isn't
gee this club it's nothing more than a
place for a few people to hang out why
did I think that everyone here saw it
the same way as I did
but that doesn't matter that we're
against getting new members or anything
pizza pie registry even gender split
why were you hoping to get AV well
that's not really something I can be
honest about is it in fact if I remember
you weren't even given a choice not to
join Monica sits down and stares at her
desk what's the point about this anyway
but if studying this club is a mistake
now you've done it NAT Sookie what me I
just spoke my mind is it a crime to be
honest it's not about being honest
it's about our choice besides you have
no right to speak for everyone else in
the club like that you don't understand
at all I just I just want a place that
feels nice to hang out with a few
friends it's our problem with the club
being that for me there aren't there are
many other places like that for me and
now Monica wants to take that away from
me she's not taking anything away
nope it's eBay it's not the same I won't
be the same with the direction she wants
to take it if I wanted that then I could
have just joined any other stupid Club
but this one I mean at least for a
little bit of time things were nice
Natsuki starts packing up her things I'm
going home I feel like I don't belong
here I knew netsuke that's the key
ignores URI and walks right out of the
classroom this is bad I don't know what
to do
well do you have an opinion on the
festival I don't know I'm kind of
indifferent I guess Oh
ah okay who cares about that obnoxious
braid I mean I like how nice and quiet
the club is right now I'm just happy
with you here but still I'm the vice
president it's not right for me to
ignore my responsibilities like that
nobody would cry and take a little dip
oh I should do my best to consider
everyone's perspective and make the
decision that's right for the club what
about you [ __ ] bang what did you want
to get out of this club let's say
jewelry repeats the same question as
Monica I decide giving me an indirect
answer is better than nothing I think
the most important thing is for everyone
to get along and for the club to provide
something that you can't get anywhere
else I don't think it's about how many
members but rather the quality of each
member that's what will end up making
the literature club a special place I
see I really agree with you each memory
contributes their own qualities in a
special way with each change in members
the identity of the club is she bleeding
from her eye she is the club as a whole
will change too I don't think that's
necessarily a bad thing
stepping out of your comfort zone once
in a while so if you would like to help
Monica with the festival then I'm on
your side as well all right well maybe
we can all talk to Natsuki tomorrow URI
nods hey URI yeah I know things were a
little awkward yesterday but I feel like
you deserve to know that I still think
you're a wonderful vice president and
also I burned it for free Monica I want
to do everything I can to make this club
this the best club ever okay me too
yeah let's go home for the day we'll
talk about the festival tomorrow okay I
look forward to should we go Pizza Bay
and listen take this the wrong way but
I'm gonna chat a little bit but pay the
baby verbally just to see what he thinks
at this time here and then it's
important to me yes president
URI looks a lot of trouble but she
doesn't protest okay I trust your
judgment Monica in that in that case I
see you two tomorrow see a demerit
Monica waves at URI as Yuri X is the
clients room there
things have been a bit hectic a they
haven't they pizza pay I want to make
sure you're enjoying your time at this
club I would really hate to see you
unhappy I feel like I'm responsible for
that i suppress then and I really do
care about you you know I don't like
seeing other girls give you a hard time
with how mean Natsuki
it's and everything and Yuri being a
little you know sometimes it feels like
you an a I heard they're only real
people here you know what I mean but
it's weird because in all the time
you've been here we've hardly gotten to
spend any time together I mean I guess
it's technically only been a couple of
days sorry I didn't mean to say
something weird there's just some things
I've been hoping to talk about with you
thanks I know only you could understand
so that's why wait oh man and then then
then oh wow we're gonna do a save there
and we're gonna end that episode there
that was quite the episode it's really
picked up a lot I'm loving this
thank you for all their support I'll see
you tomorrow squad fam
don't edit down
[Music]